how's it go seriously it's been good you
never told me yesterday how your day was
so you can tell me now I'm listening I
promise
Oh tits we're what that's a greens car
some right let's get to the bottom of
this things at least [ __ ]
Oh Don oh you missed a spot mr. clean
come to smash up the rest of our place
oh I see come to audition you [ __ ]
where's crane hiccup Oh crane
what would not nerd out with a place
like this oh all right bad if I does it
Oh snow hello hello y'all just go in
there you can't just shut the [ __ ] up we
have a problem seriously
it's 2014 what's with the phone oh you
know mr. krei please you can't help I
know you know what the plan is I J says
I can't again I'm sorry I grabbed that
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god Big B
we don't why not why the [ __ ] not
I could do anything I promise you I
didn't do anything it's girls don't let
the girls down back me up I just have to
get a stupid ring working that's all I
can't talk because that spell
but once this ring gets through I'll
know what's going on and this whole
thing will be over that's all please I'm
innocent completely completely innocent
the ring won't work
Greenleaf solji ow what no this work I
assure you it must [ __ ] is up with a guy
I don't understand like Wednesday that's
pathetic
my lips are sealed
ah [ __ ] get a haircut man
god you're bald get over man please how
many years looks what how many years has
this been going on
- two maybe but they didn't kill those
women big B please I had nothing nothing
to do with that those sideburns are not
saying you know God we found the photos
of you and Lily you perv no pets that
was I just her you snow I love I love
you and I'm sorry I'm not prince
charming okay I'm sorry I didn't cheat
on you and run away to York you don't
love me crane I know what this is
I've seen it before it is not love
but she's your wife oh I ship dumpy yep
I said it I don't think he did it
what look at him do you really think
this man murdered these women he's not
he wouldn't be brave enough I don't
think so either to be honest support his
stamp on the world life so let's let it
elaborate not a murder thank you my dear
it means so much to shut up now talk to
me okay okay what do you mean you don't
think he did it
at all if you'd seen the room I don't
need to see the room there's a lot he
has to answer for there's a lot we all
have to answer for lost cat what did you
why Prince no and you know it you said
you found evidence of him defrauding
Fabletown of using our money for his own
ambitions that's one thing but don't you
have doubts he's a murderer we've both
known him for so long I can't believe
I'm hearing this
did you see how he was acting when you
showed up yes I know how this why would
he even come here if he wasn't covering
his tracks he thought he was being
framed
he's [ __ ] up knows more than he's saying
that's for sure at least I don't what
yes
okay he probably does but there's a
difference between being involved and
being the guy who did it I mean it's
obviously rain didn't kill faith in lily
I'm sorry but who the hell did crooked
man or headless horseman this whole
thing is bigger than crane
yeah and wouldn't have the stones to
send the Tweedles after me somebody else
is involved well [ __ ]
I didn't intend for any of this to get
so you've been stealing money from
Fabletown for years haven't you yeah
we're not gonna kill you so quit you're
shivering
and you ain't getting no more about
either Ichabod Crane you are under
arrest for the misappropriation of
Fabletown funds that's it right to
counsel the right to depose witnesses
but as of right now you're coming with
us
you are extraordinarily lucky miss white
was here to save your ass cuz otherwise
I'd be on your ass not that way your
heads swinging from the Washington
Bridge that way sure that's enough this
can't be Greenleaf again and again
behaving however you like acting without
constraint I was that so bad that this
office Big B and you have to respect me
as its leader I want to know why the
last hat you think you have what it
takes to run the head office you think I
didn't may sacrifices I made sacrificing
and you won't be in that chair one
minute before you have to give up
something you care about just somehow
wheels don't fall off the goddamn wagon
I did the best I could with what I had
and the town took everything it could
out of me
- something back in return I don't I'm
just a gender energy huh you're going
away for a long time
isn't he going to arrest them
what about the lost cat I want to know
about the lost cat please anyone tell me
about the lost cat it's probably alone
and scared and doesn't know its home and
we have I hope that's a sidequest
there has to be this is not right man
who would put a lost cat sign in the
locker room of a stripper club it's an
odd choice but hey you never know with
kitties they like [ __ ]
now what sorry I want to see the Crypt
man I want to posture schemes what are
you saying
what well is that are they gonna kill
him they're gonna shoot him then I'm
gonna murder him they're gonna shoot him
they're gonna do a shootout this is the
show that this is yep yep yep
yeah
[ __ ] are we going to do
and to shoot our baby
I would tell the snow to run and use him
as shield oh [ __ ] is that the no that
was a girl there what the [ __ ]
who is she what is happening
look it's recently come under our
attention that you're passionate with
this attempting to claim what is the
personal property of the Crooked Man
oh it's crooked it's about yay high 120
odd pounds pissed his sheets until he
was 14 sound familiar
I haven't told him anything the
grown-ups are talking
what do you want that sack of flour
crane dear its crane it wasn't my fault
oh hello
you're interfering with official
Fabletown business step aside Tweedledee
what's the app you know that thing the
Mondays call me a [ __ ] what won't I
nickname you know what I'm talking who
is she who is she uh Bloody Bloody Mary
huh
and do you know why they call me that
because you're always on your parents
to their little bathrooms and say my
name five times in the mirror they find
it less funny when I actually show up
and feed their lungs family dog ed get
would never ever eat my lungs that for a
hobby my god to relax
this is my job I like my job so think
about what I'm gonna do to your girl and
the rest of your hands if you don't hand
over the sock puppet
now you can [ __ ] off if you think you're
getting him I told you he'd never just
give him up I don't like this [ __ ] it
well you [ __ ] with the wrong wolf
[ __ ] be nice
he's gone hmm oh [ __ ] Oh
oh stop hello gates are you doing mail
thingy you want to play you wanna play
what am I supposed I'm just supposed to
hold it back
I'm clicking like a [ __ ]
Jesus Christ is a [ __ ] tank
holy [ __ ] man calm down
oh geez May dieting good main fat it
good huh
I ran out of my mo hon Jesus yep
why am I supposed to do here [ __ ]
crazy
I'm at the [ __ ] is she
but you know they just didn't know when
to end
oh she has the woods man Thanks
work on anything but a pure where will
but as it turns out it's just
right
I mean hey look I know it sounds
ridiculous but really guys can you argue
with these results oh oh
Glinka what do you want from me you can
have crane I can't believe it I [ __ ]
kill that guy take okay take prang just
stop please hmm yeah I don't know yes
get out of here
it's your lucky day kid crooked man says
it's okay with him
hello a goodbye
what that Bach so much just [ __ ]
happened and I feel like I'm Oh
just between us girls create no killer I
mean look at his face couldn't stick up
a pig is my
Jesus Chris
nope not like your boyfriend no I [ __ ]
really I mean it
that [ __ ] bad direction we'll be in
touch see you around it just happened so
fast
what the [ __ ] if a man
you
he's lucky to be alive and he won't be
next time if he keeps going like this
Jesus this is getting worse by the
minute we don't have time to sit around
and wait for their next move I'll get
things under control
woody not gonna tell you again
back off dog this doesn't concern you
what you want to talk about it I just
wanted to lets her about last night I
think we do that's why people hear what
you did to dumb they're going to think
you've gone back to your old ways don't
hold out on me jack
you've always got some angle not this
time I know when a mark is not worth the
trouble
do you don't let me come down there to
deal with you I don't want it you don't
want it then again you don't have much
choice at this point do you [ __ ] L is
awesome else miss F so so far Jesus
Christ I [ __ ] any man I don't know
what happened but I can't what okay
we're gonna go through this now don't
don't you worry don't you worry ty okay
you and 83% of players decided not to
interrupt snella score baby so there you
can't [ __ ] all right
I mean if I've heard thinking the same
way and bro-face if you date and not a
punch it's bro-face what place did you
investigate first you and 35.4 so it
seems that you went the whole most
people into Holly first now wonder why
done diddly diddly what did you do that
I didn't okay well whatever it didn't
seem that important anyway did you make
dad make a deal with Jack 69 well I
don't think is really bad I don't really
care did you burn down green leaves 380
2.5% why would you burn down a poor
lady's face
geez
Oh goddamn it this is gonna be
controversial you and 46 as I have that
was a tough choice man that was a really
tough choice I just went with my gut he
[ __ ] try to kill us so many times I
just felt like I'm done with this guy
he's dead
you know don't look at me like that
he shot Holly and all this [ __ ]
happening because he keeps killing
people and I feel bad because he has a
twin and out a tween he's gonna have to
deal with that too but he's got damn it
or Jeff Allah calm down Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] all right
I was [ __ ] awesome thank you for
watching this episode can't wait for the
next one
that was definitely the best episode so
far I think at least but that is my
opinion about things I had a lot of fun
playing it and I hope you enjoyed
watching it
III think it's cool I like to see I keep
saying it but I like this series because
it's just you and me baby there's no a
cut to cut a sing part and stuff I don't
know I don't know what I'm talking about
and but yeah it's awesome so I'll see
you next one and until then stay awesome
love your breasts